THAT WAS A GREAT TRIBUTE.
♪
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN AND VLADIMIR
PUTIN SHARE SOMETHING IN COMMON.
THEY ARE BOTH RUNNING INTO SOME
PROBLEMS AT HOME.
AND BOTH MEN ARE USING SIMILAR
TACTICS TO HIDE THE TRUTH.
WE EXPECT THAT FROM THE RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT, NOT OUR PRESIDENT.
BUT START IN RUSSIA.
PUTIN CAN'T KEEP A LID ON
REALITY DURING A WAR.
THIS IS 2022.
THE DAM IS CRACKING.
CHECK OUT THIS NEWS EDITOR WHO
CRASHED A LIVE BROADCAST TO LET
THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE KNOW WHAT'S
BEEN GOING ON.
MORE ON THIS IN A MOMENT.
BUT, PUTIN HAS RUN INTO
RESISTANCE EVERYWHERE SO HE IS
CRANKING UP THE PROPAGANDA TO
LEVELS WE HAVEN'T SEEN SINCE
2014.
WHEN HE INVADED CRIMEA, HE PUTIN
KINIS STARTED POPPING UP ALL
OVER THE BEACHES.
RUSSIAN WOMEN WERE SEEN SPORTING
PUTIN BIKINIS TO PUSH PATRIOTISM
AND SHOW SUPPORT FOR RUSSIA'S
INTEREST.
AND NOW PUTIN IS LOOKING FOR NEW
SOURCES OF DISINFORMATION.
RUSSIA IS PAYING YOUNG RUSSIAN
TIKTOK STARS TO PUSH HIS TALKING
POINTS.
THE VIDEOS FOLLOW THE EXACT SAME
SCRIPT LIKE A KREMLIN PRESS
RELEASE, ACTUALLY.
WATCH.
>> WHERE DID PUTIN GET THIS IDEA
FROM?
WELL, MAYBE HE WAS WATCHING THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE.
FOR THE LAST YEAR, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN USING
IDIOTIC TIKTOK VIDEOS TO PUSH,
FOR INSTANCE, VACCINATIONS ON
KIDS.
>> BING BOP ARE YOU VACCINATED?
>> YES, SIR.
>> HEY, YEP.
>> DID WE GET IT.
>> WE GOT IT.
>> HI, MY NAME IS COOPER AND
THIS IS A DAY IN MY LIFE AS A
WHITE HOUSE INTERN.
>> WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY IN
OUR FIGHT AGAINST THIS VIRUS.
WE HAVE VACCINATED 106 MILLION
AMERICANS.
ARE YOU GETTING THIS ALL DOWN?
>> DON'T WORRY QUEEN, ALL ARE
HERE.
>> THINGS ARE GOTTEN PRETTY BAD
POLITICALLY FOR JOE BIDEN SINCE
THEN IF YOU CAN IMAGINE.
SO HE ASKED ACTUAL TEENAGERS FOR
HELP, THAT'S RIGHT.
HE INVITED 30 TIKTOK STARS TO A
ZOOM CALL FOR A BRIEFING ON THE
WAR IN UKRAINE.
WELL, THE REAL GOAL WAS TO PUSH
PARTISAN GOVERNMENT PROPAGANDA
AND THE KIDS ACTUALLY DID IT.
>> WE ARE SEEING THE UNITED
STATES SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA WORK.
RUSSIA'S ECONOMY IS IN FREE
FALL, THE RUBLE IS AT ITS LOWEST
POINT.
>> A NO-FLY ZONE IS MORE
EQUIVALENT TO BOOTS ON THE
GROUND MILITARY ACTION.
>> THE TYPE OF ACTION WOULD
ESCALATE THE WAR FURTHER AND
CAUSE FAR MORE DAMAGE.
>> RUSSIA IS ONE OF THE TOP
THREE PRODUCERS OF OIL.
PUTIN IS STARTING THIS HORRIFIC
FIGHT BETWEEN UKRAINE AND
RUSSIA.
NOBODY WANT TO WORK WITH HIM TO
DO INTERNATIONAL TRADE.
PEOPLE WAR AND LIMITED RESOURCES
PRICES ARE BOUND TO GO UP AS
WELL.
>> Jesse: INSTEAD OF INVITING
AMERICAN ENERGY CEOs TO A
WHITE HOUSE MEETING, YOU KNOW,
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE HELL IS
GOING ON WITH GAS PRICES, JOE IS
INVITING TEENAGERS OVER FOR A
LITTLE PROPAGANDA PARTY.
THE KIDS ARE VERY EASY TO
MANIPULATE.
AND BIDEN KNOWS THAT.
SO INSTEAD OF FIXING PROBLEMS,
BIDEN JUST GETS PUPPETS TO POINT
FINGERS.
TIKTOK IS FULL OF KIDS MAKING
STUPID VIDEOS, SWALLOWS TIDE
POTS, PUTTING PENNIES A ELECTRIC
SOCKET OR SETTING THINGS ON FIRE
OR JUST DANCING.
♪ DANCING QUEEN
♪ YOUNG AND SWEET
♪ ONLY 17
♪
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT IS USING
A DANCE APP. FOR DISINFORMATION
AND TIKTOK IS OWNED BY THE
CHINESE.
CHINESE COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT
CONTROLS A LARGE STAKE OF THE
COMPANY.
EVEN BIDEN'S PROPAGANDA IS MADE
IN CHINA.
MAYBE THE REASON BIDEN IS
TURNING TO TEENAGERS TO PUSH HIS
LITTLE PROPAGANDA IS BECAUSE THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA WON'T DO IT FOR
HIM THAT MUCH ANYMORE.
REMEMBER NANCY PELOSI TOLD THE
PRESS THEY NEEDED TO DO A BETTER
JOB OF SELLING THE DEMOCRATS'
AGENDA AT THE END OF LAST YEAR?
WELL, CLEARLY THEY DIDN'T
LISTEN.
HOSTS AREN'T FALLING IN LINE
LIKE THEY USED TO ANYMORE.
WATCH.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS,
INFLATION REALLY STARTED TO RISE
ALMOST EXACTLY WHEN BIDEN CAME
INTO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> 'PUTIN THOUGHT TRUMP WAS
REALLY THAT SUPPORTIVE OF HIM,
WHY DIDN'T HE INVADE WHEN TRUMP
WAS IN OFFICE?
THAT'S AT LEAST WORTH ASKING
THAT QUESTION IF YOU ARE NOT
LOCKED INTO ONE INTRIANGLE JENT
THOUGHT.
>> APPARENTLY SAUDI ARABIA WON'T
PICK UP THE PHONE FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU CAN SAY WHAT YOU WANT?
BUT THIS WOULD HAVE NEVER
HAPPENED TO DONALD TRUMP.
>> Jesse: WHEN JOE DOESN'T HAVE
THE MEDIA TO SAY NOTHING IS HIS
FAULT HE USES CHILD ALLEGE
TORES.
WHAT TYPE OF TOPICS WERE COME UP
ON THIS TIKTOK ZOOM CALL BESIDES
UKRAINE?
, THE RUSSIA HOAX.
>> THE BEST ANTIDOTE TO
DISINFORMATION IS THE TRUTH.
IF YOU LOOK BACK AT 2014 AND
FRANKLY EVEN 2016, WHEN RUSSIA
INVADED UKRAINE AND THEN IN 2016
WHEN THEY, YOU KNOW, OF COURSE
HACKED OUR ELECTION HERE, IT --
WE DID NOT DO THAT, RIGHT?
WE DID NOT -- WE DID NOT
[INAUDIBLE] INFORMATION.
>> BUT BIDEN COULDN'T EVEN
CONVINCE ALL THE YOUNG KIDS TO
SELL THAT.
ONE OF THE YOUNG GUYS ON THE
CALL WITH THE WHITE HOUSE TOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST," QUOTE:
THE OVERALL TONE OF THE BRIEFING
WAS TOO SOFT.
AND THAT OFFICIALS DODGED HARD
QUESTIONS.
FELT LIKE A PRESS BRIEFING FOR
KINDERGARTENS.
AND SPEAKING OF KINDERGARTENERS
THIS WHITE HOUSE HAS A HISTORY
OF USING THEM.
>> MY MOM WAS A SCIENTIST AND I
JUST LOVE THE IDEA OF EXPLORING
THE UNKNOWN.
>> WE JUST HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT
OR DISCOVERED YET.
WAIT UNTIL THEY SEE THE MOON.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS ABOUT
THOSE CRATERS ON THE MOON.
AGAIN EVENING PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
NOT EVEN MADE IN AMERICA.
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" DUMPED ON
THE STUNT.
>> THANK YOU FOR COMING AND
ANSWERING YOUR NATION'S CALL IN
A TIME OF NEED.
>> SURE NO PROBLEM.
>> I'M 12 I.
>> I WANT TO THANK MY PRESS
SECRETARY.
>> I SUGGESTED IT AS A JOKE AND
THEN IT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
>> PEOPLE ARE SAYING THIS IS A
FIRST WAR FOUGHT ON TIKTOK WHICH
IS TOUGH FOR ME BECAUSE I'M THE
LAND LINE OF PRESIDENTS.
>> THE SAD REALITY IS, THIS
ISN'T FUNNY, IT'S INSULTING,
ALSO, THE SIMILARITIES BETWEEN
AMERICAN LEFT WING IDEOLOGY AND
RUSSIAN STATISM IS PRETTY
STRIKING.
WE SHOWED YOU THIS VIDEO BEFORE.
RUSSIA ARRESTING PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA FOR SPEAKING OUT AGAINST
THE KREMLIN NOW.
VLAD CREATED A LAW TO BAN PEOPLE
FROM SPREADING WHAT HE CALLS
FAKE NEWS.
DOES THAT SOUND FAMILIAR?
DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA SPENT THE
LAST TWO YEARS ADVOCATING FOR
THAT.
THEY HAVE BEEN CONSISTENTLY
TRYING TO SILENCE CONSERVATIVES
AND CALL ANYTHING THEY DON'T
LIKE MISINFORMATION.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA HAS BEEN
CALLING FOR A SILENCING OF FOX
SINCE RUSSIA INVADED UKRAINE.
BECAUSE APPARENTLY IF YOU ASK
QUESTIONS AND RAISE ISSUES
OUTSIDE THE MAINSTREAM, IT MUST
MEAN THAT YOU'RE THE ENEMY OF
THE STATE.
OR NOW EVEN CALLING FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO GO AFTER
TUCK AND TULSI GABBARD AND SHUT
THEM UP.
>> WHAT TUCKER CARLSON PARROTS
EVERY NIGHT ON FOX NEWS, WHAT
TULSI GABBARD IS SPREADING IS
ACTUALLY HELPING PUTIN GET AWAY
WITH CRIMINAL ACTS AGAINST
INNOCENT UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS.
>> I THINK DOJ AND THE SAME WAY
THAT IT IS SETTING UP A TASK
FORCE TO INVESTIGATE OLIGARCHS
SHOULD LOOK INTO PEOPLE WHO ARE
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDISTS AND
SHILLING FOR PUTIN.
THAT BEING IF YOU ARE A FOREIGN
ASSET TO A DICTATOR, IT SHOULD
BE INVESTIGATED.
>> THEY USED TO ARREST PEOPLE
FOR DOING STUFF LIKE THIS.
>> Jesse: EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD
BE WONDERING WHY OUR WHITE HOUSE
AND OUR DEMOCRATIC PARTY SEEM TO
BE MIMICKING PUTIN'S PROPAGANDA
STYLE AND SEEKING OUT WAYS TO
SILENCE FREE SPEEC